it's finally here but we can't kick off
all weekends may 24 oh yeah we've got
beers to drink and burgers to crush and
pedicures to show off if the weather
decides to cooperate but these BBQ
Pollock's tend to be all you can eat
events they're like a smorgasbord of
mail Laden sugary sauce dripping beer
chugging feet things could get a little
bit bloated down there but don't worry I
partner with my friends at liberty to
bring you my top 5 tips for navigating
the BBQ potluck this weekend let's get
to it tip 1 have a snack before you go
arriving to your family BBQ in a hangry
rage state is pretty much a recipe for
being super rude to Uncle Joe and eating
way too many slider burgers it's not a
good combination so I always recommend
having a little snack before you go
ideally some learn the fiber protein and
healthy fats that's going to keep you
feeling fuller longer tip to load up on
the grilled vegetables and the green
salad and try to take it easy on things
like tater salad pasta salad and even
bean salad which Believe It or Not can
pack quite a lot of extra oil and sugar
Oh in the biggest nono stay away from
that jello salad that Aunt Sue makes I
don't even know where she got that
recipe but god help anyone that has to
eat it tip 3 Philip on lean protein
protein keeps you feeling fuller longer
so you'll be less tempted by the nachos
the ice cream or that jello salad so
look for lean sources of protein like
skinless boneless chicken breast beef
tenderloin pork tenderloin and fish and
seafood or if you can't find a leaner
option just trim the fat or take off the
skip chipboard sip slowly when we overdo
it on the fun
it can be really easy to make bad
decisions both for our diet and
otherwise hmm I'm recommend having a cup
or two of water in between each serving
of alcohol and if you're going for beer
maybe split that ear in popsies and go
half and half with some friends sharing
means caring right if wines more your
thing why not try a spritzer with have
wine and half sparkling water or if you
like it hard just to a half amps liquor
with lots of ice and your favorite non
calorie mixer tip 5 bring the light
depth dish to the party that everyone
will love showing up to the pollak
empty-handed that's just rude so I
always bring something with me on hand
that I feel is a nice lighter choice and
my family's favorite recipe are these
low carb chicken tacos with a pineapple
avocado salsa so this recipe calls for
skinless boneless chicken breast and
it's really important that you choose
one that's really high quality so I
always look for something that's raised
about any antibiotics added hormones or
animal by-product so I love Liberty
reason these tacos are totally
gluten-free really low in carbs and they
can also be made dairy-free if you just
want to omit the cheese at the end let's
make some tacos so I'm going to start by
putting my skinless boneless chicken
breasts inside a plastic bag that I can
reseal into a food processor I'm going
to make my marinade with some cumin so
olive oil some cilantro lime juice from
chipotle in adobo sauce some lime zest
and a little bit of salt and pepper
and now i'm just going to puree that
until get some nice and smooth so i'm
going to transfer that to my resealable
bag with my chicken breast and let it
sit in the fridge for about two or three
hours so now it's time to grill I clean
off my grill of course and oil it down
lightly and I preheat it to about 375
degrees about the medium high heat so
cuts one quarter inch rings of pineapple
I'm just going to lay them down on the
grill until they get nice and golden on
both sides so now it's time to add the
chicken and i always put on direct heat
first so it gets a nice caramelized
crust and then I transfer it to indirect
heat to finish cooking till it gets to
about 165 degrees internally once it's
cooked I'm going to remove it from the
grill and just let it sit for about five
minutes before I start to cut it into
strips now let's make our salsa so I
take that grilled pineapple and we just
chop it up into a nice fine dice and I
mix it up with some avocado some red
onion a little help and you'll for a
nice kick some more cilantro some lime
juice some honey just to sweeten things
up and a little bit of salt and pepper
just to taste we're just mix that up get
it all ready to go and now let's make
our tacos
yeah I am so excited about this weekend
I have been waiting for me to for since
last year so grab a friend grab a drink
grab a taco and house an amazing time
this weekend thank you so much for
watching if you liked what you saw give
it a thumbs up leave me a comment below
about what you're going to be making on
May 24 subscribe to my channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen okay
I don't I say you'll heck dark